[Musique]
je nomme donc vient d'arriver sur
mulhouse n'est pas au courant donc ne
parle pas français
donc il ne sait pas écrire donc on lui a
donné des conseils on lui a montré
comment faire et on lui a fait n'était
pas présente il a cette fois ci donc on
dire expliqué que la prochaine fois ça
sera un peu plus répressives je trouve
que c'est une bonne idée
et puis si ça permet de ré situation
s'améliore c'est bien ça cette sortie à
19h45 drame deux heures mais vous allez
être verbalisé monsieur donc là
normalement vous avez une activité assez
importante vous allez de la circulation
normalement on n'a pas le temps de
discuter
et comme vous voyez là tous les déserts
rappaz